the numbers are in for the GTX 1070
Founders Edition video card despite
being in taipe Taiwan this week for
computex which is coming up in a few
days we managed to pull off a full
Benchmark and review of the card with
all the usual FPS thermals and
architecture analysis before getting to
that content all of this coverage for
the first few days of computex is
brought to you by MSI and the new x99a
gaming motherboards including the gaming
Pro carbon here's a Specs table first
off check the article for full detail on
the GTX 1070 we've compressed it heavily
to fit into a video format but you'll
get additional game tests and Detail in
the article the GTX 1070 operates on the
GP 104 GPU from Nvidia starring the
Pascal architecture the reference GTX
1080 also operates on a GP 104 but
they're differentiated by subversion and
the 1070 is a GP 104 -200 that's the
important bit the 1080 is the GP 104
-400 the silicon's the same the
architecture is mostly the same but the
die has been somewhat simplified on the
GTX 1070 to reduce cost the heart of the
chip is still the 16 NM finfet design
which operates at a slightly lower
voltage than the planer process
previously and Exhibits less power
leakage than planer data path
optimizations are also in place for
performance improvements something we
spent a few thousand words in our GTX
1080 review covering if you're curious
about that the first major change to the
1070 is SM count the GP 1042 200 GPU has
15 SMS rather than the 20 SMS on the GP
1044 because of the SM reduction tmus
are naturally also reduced the 1070
operates on 120 tmus and those can pipe
202 gigx per second core counts is airm
1920 CTIC cor is operating at a boosted
clock of 1683 MHz stock the 1070 also
uses gddr5 not 5x and that's at 8 gbits
per second with a capacity of 8 gbes
time to dive into the benchmarks first I
know that's what everyone wants to see
right away as always all the
methodologies find on the website links
in the description below along with
additional game benchmarks that aren't
shown here if you're curious about how
we test those things here's a look at
the temperatures for the GTX 1080 and
GTX 1070 Founders edition cards we've
also got the 1080 hybrid on here which
is a card that we built custom from the
scraps of a 980 TI hybrid and a
desecrated 1080 reference card or
Founders Edition card the GTX 1070
operates about equal to the GTX 980
reference with hitting 53.86 C Delta
temperature over ambient which is a few
degrees cooler than the GTX 1080 Fe at
57 up 5 1 CSI that extra few degrees
will actually help give us some extra
head room in overclocking we'll discuss
later on as you'll see in our three-part
hybrid build Series where we explore the
temperature limitations the fury X sits
at 36.3 n CI is a bit warmer than the
other liquid cooled cards but that's
because Fury cools its vrm and memory
with liquid as well not just the GPU the
1070 is about 6.55% cooler than the GTX
1080 entirely resultant of the die
simplification and here's a look at The
Thermals over time chart this data is
pulled from the same tests as the peak
load temperature average and shows the
test data over time the Nvidia Founders
Edition cooler isn't particularly
impressive but it is reasonable in the
very least the Fe cooler performs about
where previous reference models have
performed but as always aib Partners
will make significantly more effective
coolers on their cards that FV cooler
operates with a maximum fan noise level
of about 47 to 50 DB which is reasonable
when compared to other devices just a
reminder these are delta values this
means we subtract ambient so add your
own ambient temperature back in when
you're looking at these numbers if your
house is about 70f 20 Celsius you add in
20 Celsius to these numbers that gives
you the operating temperature of the GPU
in your environment and we remove Delta
we do the Delta value for a few reasons
so subtracting ambient helps control for
the natural variance with the HVAC
system between tests and it also
obviously helps you compare on your own
ambient temperature since ours is not
the same as yours so here's a brief
endurance chart this show shows the
frequency over time versus temperatures
as you can see the 1070 sustains a
pretty stable frequency throughout the
endurance of the test you can read more
about this in the article Link in the
description below time to talk about
game benchmarking now we've got a mix of
the usual openg dx11 apps but we've also
got some of the new dx12 and Vulcan
applications and we're going to start
off with doom which is brand new from ID
software and runs on openg GL with
Vulcan support coming in the immediate
future Doom is one of the few games
where the GTX 1070 performs slower than
the GTX 980ti and ra frame throughput
the two cards trade blows depending on
game and the 1070 often matches evenly
or outmatches the GTX 980 TI the
previous Flagship the GTX 980 TI runs
about 11.5% faster than the GTX 1070 and
raw frame throughput at 1080p the GTX
1080 ties with the 980 TI only because
we've hit a CPU bottleneck and the 1070
sits below the CPU throttle Point
hitting nearly 115 FPS average with
tightly timed 1% and 0.1% lowf frame
metrics 80.3 and 72.7 respectively
against amd's current high-end single
GPU card the GTX 1070 outperforms The R9
Fury X by about
8.8% or 114.3 FPS on the 1070 versus 105
average on the fury X against the 970
Nvidia successor the 1070 pushes an
additional 12.7% frames per second 1440p
plants the GTX 1070 firmly within
playable range running above 70 FPS and
4K begins to stress the card a little
too much for a perfect fit with regard
to frame times and fluidity moving on to
the division it appears that 1080p
testing is too easy on the GTX 1070 it
doesn't choke the card for frame rate
until we move to higher resolutions at
1440p the GTX 1070 runs at about 18.4%
slower than the GTX 1080 and about even
with the 980 TI the 10 the 970 sits at
55.7 FPS which is
23.7% slower in fps than the 1070 at
1440p 4K is a little too intense for the
GTX 10 1070 in the division though the
1080 has a lot less issue with it and
Remains the only single GPU card that
can regularly handle 4K gaming at very
high is settings and the 1070 could play
in 4k but you'd have to drop the medium
and low settings looking at shadow of
mortar the 1070 holds a strong second
place following the 1080 by 17% and
leading the 980 TI by 8.3% at 1080p that
gets switched around as the resolution
increases with 1440p establishing a
massive lead on the $700 1080 though at
these frame rates it really be somewhat
relevant until stepping into 4K anyway
and pushes the 98 and fury X beyond the
1070 The 1070 still sits at 77 FPS fully
playable and marks itself an easily
defined improvement over the 970 at 48.7
FPS or 45% different and it's still
fairly affordable as well let's move on
to dx12 benchmarks so ashes of
Singularity is the first of those
benchmarks for Simplicity of
presentation we've broken into a few
charts with ashes of Singularity the
first one shows dx12 versus dx1 11
performance all of this data is from the
satellite Shot 2 part of the Benchmark
nvidia's GTX 1070 Founders Edition lands
in second place on the 1080p chart with
10 FPS disparity between the brand new
$700 1080 and the $450 1070 that's a
14.27% Delta for a couple hundred the
gtx970 runs approximately 35.172923
lower frame rates with dx11 something we
analyzed in the 1080 review you'll find
that again below and the fury X
eliminates the GTX 1070s lead once
resolution is increased this chart next
shows the ashes of Singularity frame
times and that's the latency between
frames this is comparing dx12 to dx1
Performance gains between architectures
so you're looking at percent Delta
versus the previous generation versus
the previous API and as shown nvidia's
move to asynchronous compute algorithms
and compute preemption has assisted
tremendously in its performance game G
over the Maxwell generation we'll
explain compute preemption and Nvidia
ASN computes in our 1080 review so if
you want to learn about that again hit
that content the 1070 sees benefits and
Architectural changes to data path
organization and compute preemption
ultimately yielding an additional
28.3% frame time improvement over dx11
this isn't quite as good as the GTX 1080
is near 50% gains but it's still pretty
damn good AMD of course looks about 120%
gains dx11 to 12 with the fury X but a
lot of that is just because of Andy's
tremendously low performance in dx11
next up is Vulcan with the tals
principal at 1440p the GTX 1070
performance still stands above the 60
FPS Mark well above it in fact with 110
FPS average on Vulcan and 119 average on
dx11 and even manages to hold marginally
above 60 FPS performance at 4K the 1080
performance for GTX 1070 runs 12.2%
slower than the GTX 1080 2.6% faster
than than the 98 reference and that's a
difference that pre-overclocked 98 would
overcome the last gen Maxwell GTX 970
runs about 37% slower than the 1070 we
made a big deal out of overclocking on
the new Pascal architecture with our GTX
1080 review and part of that is because
we tore the thing apart and threw the
liquid cooler on there to see just how
far we could actually push it once The
Thermals were accounted for uh so the
things that changed here first of all
it's on Boost 3.0 now which is a new
version of nvidia's boost technology and
that does change things a little bit for
overclocking including the introduction
of scan OC on EVGA Precision which means
that you'll be able to sort of
semi-automatically scan for and set your
overclock including a frequency versus
voltage curve that's brand new we don't
use that though we do the tried and
truee true sort of basic overclocking
method which is really just slider
tuning so you tune the core clock memory
clock and then the voltage as necessary
along with fan RPMs or just throw a
liquid cooler on there and that's how we
do our overclocking for these tests but
let's look at the table with our
stepping results for overclocking
this table shows our progress stepping
as we tested each modification to the
GPU our final tested results burned in
with an endurance test and stayed strong
a 1987 MHz core 4608 MHz memory and
that's a 215 MHz overclock on the core
and 6 600 MHz overclock on the memory
which only seem limited by vbios and
voltage regulation at this point not
necessarily an uncommon thing what
you're looking at now are the
performance charts for that overclock
some games saw more than a 25 5%
performance increase but the range was a
more reasonable 9 to 30% GTA 5 at 4K
benefited from a 12.6% gain on the 1070
with a 1080 benefiting 14.88% on the Fe
cooler Mordor at 4K a 29.9% hike at
1080P and at 1440p that was still 23.3%
with the 1070 overclocked Doom at 1080p
moves into the 120 HZ playable range
with a 99.2% jaunt to 25.7 FPS average
the GP 10420 chip runs cooler by nature
of its simplified die and it's lower
overall clock rate but there are other
things to look at too so the 1070 trades
blows with the 980 TI and that
difference could be made up for in some
cases by a pre-overclocked aib version
of the 98 so do keep that in mind
overall the 1070 is a good improvement
over the 970 from the previous Maxwell
generation and that Improvement measures
about maximally maybe 30% but we do see
a pretty good range in there depending
on a lot of things like the game but
generally you see about a 30% Delta
between the 970 and the 1070 until
pushing into higher resolution so 1440p
is a good example of that the 1070
creates a new emergent class of of 1440p
ready cards for uh 60 FPS plus gaming
and this is something that the 1080 did
for 4K as well where it finally exceeded
60 FPS on a single GPU with the 1080 and
the 1070 does that for 1440p as for the
the founders Edition card we're taking
the same stance with this as we took the
1080 Founders Edition card and that is
you should wait for the a models so the
aib models we priced in the 350 to $450
range whether it's the Fe card is priced
at $450 so that price difference is
enough to justify the purchase of an aib
card because it's a good good amount of
different you'll save more money put it
towards something else the aib cards of
course will also be better overclockers
in some regard when looking at things
like Heat versus noise so if you're
trying to reduce your noise levels but
also uh overclock that's sometimes
difficult with the reference cards
because the blower fan has to increase
in its RPM so that's a big thing to look
at I would suggest waiting for the aib
cards other than that the 1070 is a good
chip it performs well performs where you
would want it to be and if you're
playing at 1440p that makes it
exceptionally good because nothing
really exists at this price point that
can do 1440p right now so in that regard
this is setting a new standard for
NVIDIA uh I would not buy it for 1080p
you're good buying something cheaper for
that because this is just overkill for
1080p in almost all instances so that is
our GTX 1070 review
as always thank you for watching full
article links in the description below
for more information patreon link the
post video if you want to help us out
directly with your contributions over
time and of course a big thanks to Mike
gagon Andy Burke ke Gall Andrew Coleman
who all helped pull this thing together
remotely across continents while we're
in taipe Taiwan for compex so thank you
for watching I'll see you all next
[Music]
time